11 Bitcoin ETFs are going to begin
trading to day after the SEC approved
their applications the move overturned a
decade of The Regulators opposition to
the idea sure what any of this means
though when right palm will talk about
it but when when they finally say it's
okay maybe we talked about it may maybe
it's over maybe the in maybe all the
people that got in there early now say
I'm going to I'm going to offload it to
the sheep that can now get in with the
ETF well I think in the short term there
are clearly people who've been buying up
in the last three months on
the expectation of this and the question
is no longer term maybe a very different
story do the holders finally do holders
ever sell I don't know I I don't think
hold owners ever sell but I do think
this is a historic moment in the sense
of it's the first time that the internet
and Wall Street they've had this healthy
tension for a couple of years uh even a
couple decades and it's the first time
Wall Street blinked right think of it
it's an internet-based asset that now is
being arms wrapped around by Wall Street
and to your point um now that everyone
can buy it financial advisers are saying
okay ETF uh Regulators are on board I'm
going to put in on everyone's portfolio
the volatility is going to drastically
dampen from here but then it could make
the move to Andrew's currency that it's
never been they the point you can't you
you you don't want to buy a pizza for
$25,000 they said there's too much
volatility for it to ever be transaction
as a store value maybe it makes but if
it has no more volatility maybe it turns
into something I think like that when I
say no more uh volatility or volatility
is going to dampen what I mean is uh
over the last four years Bitcoin has had
a compound anal growth rate of over 50%
then people like oh that's on aable for
four years but if you go back over the
last 10 years it's still been 50%
compound anual growth rate and so what I
think will happen is it'll just start to
taper off a little bit and in the next
five years or so it'll be like 20% Which
is still double with the stock that
won't get to Tom Le's
500,000 though well but the I think what
you're asking is a different question is
it a financial asset it appears to very
much be a financial asset right does it
become does it become transaction is it
a currency yeah that's a much ethereum
might be some form of a a lot more than
Bitcoin today there a lot of other there
are probably a lot of from a
technological perspective a lot better
actually um different Technologies in
the blockchain for that purpose if
that's what you think this is yeah
there's another interesting thing that's
happening right so if I go on Wall
Street and I ask people uh what is your
benchmark they'll tell me the S&P maybe
NASDAQ right they have these uh Equity
based benchmarks if I go ask a 25 year
old or younger Bitcoin is The Benchmark
and so the reason why that's interesting
is there's an entire generation of
people who say if I can't beat Bitcoin
that I might as well just buy it and
that's why you see those people the only
thing they're allocating to is Bitcoin
or the longtail of crypto assets they're
basically speculating on and so as those
people age now Bitcoin becomes that
Benchmark it's going to get into
everyone's portfolio so volatility will
dampen down but ultimately if you want
Mass adoption everyone's got to put in
their portfolio right and so the days of
the asymmetric th% increases in a single
year are probably gone but an asset
that's compounding at 20 30 40 50% a
year you can't get that in the stock
market so I still think it'll be very
like that though I mean if if it becomes
less volatile if you have everybody able
to get into it to do these things does
it still have growth like that there's a
really interesting mechanism here where
we've never had an ETF of a finite asset
right every asset is got some degree of
uh increasing or expanding Supply this
is a finite asset and so now all of a
sudden you have what could be tens of
billions hundreds of billions depending
on who you ask that's going to come into
this over the next say 10 years but
there's still only 21 million gold ETFs
aren't there but gold still this Supply
is expanded but not expand very fast
right same with Bitcoin though for so
when when's the last Bitcoin going to be
mine 21 2140 2140 and then you got to
also remember there's 70% of the Bitcoin
that hasn't moved in the last year and
so now we have institutions that are
banging on the door and and I think it's
important to talk about uh the fees that
have changed as well right if you look
at uh bitwise is now the cheapest
Bitcoin Fund in America in the sense of
it's
0.24% um uh fee and they just dropped it
down to 0.20 that's a 90% uh difference
between where it was you know a couple
days ago in terms of the publicly
available Bitcoin fund why did all of
these ETFs say that they were lowering
their fees too like in the last war yes
I mean this is a few and that's what I
mean is it going to be profitable for
anybody there's there's a huge amount of
demand that's built up but there's also
a huge amount of players who want to
meet that demand so if you look gray
scale was at 2% they dropped to one and
a half percent right and people like why
didn't they drop all the way down to 0
2% well big thing is if you want to go
sell your great scale and try to roll
somewhere else you're going have to pay
taxes unless you're in a tax advantage
account so there's a lot of assets that
are going to stay in great scale right
right and those guys will never get
enough credit for pushing this issue and
really kind of helping push it forward
but I think that uh what you see is GRA
saying hey we already have a lot of
assets let's hold on to what we have and
everyone else saying we want all the new
assets that are going to come in so we
got to go compete in the fee war and so
0.2 point3 point4 how much does it
really matter some advisers really care
other advisers say hey I just want to
buy something that's a great product I
think is going to track the price
correctly but what I think is going to
ultimately end up occurring is there's
going to be tens of billions of dollars
that are going to flow into these ETFs
you have a finite asset so it will go up
how many how many of these ETFs do you
think will exist in a year or two from
now I think so much consolidation or
some of them just decide I'm not doing
this anymore I think there will be more
12 months from now in the aggregate
number but there will be a clear two to
three winners right and so my guess is
that black rock um will end up being
very very successful I think gra scale
will hold on to a lot of assets and then
there's kind of this competition among
what I'd say all of the like digital or
internet-based uh kind of innovation
Tech uh type ETFs they're all going to
go fight it out and so if you have three
big Winners right then that ends up
being probably tens of billions do right
is that a huge consolidation War yeah
it's basically everyone will will keep
it because they want it right there's a
lot of people who have the S&P you know
index even though they don't have a lot
of Assets in it fit you think long term
this is and I asked this and we'll show
a little bit of the interview I think
later with Brian Armstrong of coinbase
do you think this is good for the robin
hoods and coin bases of the world or not
because the truth is if you know long
longer need to get a coinbase account
because you can buy this through your
Fidelity account yeah what does it
actually I mean look they're going to
make money because they're going to be a
custodian on the other side of it but
that's a different business so um I've
invested in Bitcoin I've invested in a
lot of equities across this thing and
and this is an interesting day because
uh I'm an investor in 21 shares I'm an
investor in coinbase I'm an investor in
bitwise and so I'm seeing kind of how
each one of them is playing this out and
one of the things that's most
interesting is the ETF fee War May leak
out into custody fee war and also
exchange fee War so coinbase may have to
drop their fees because um it may be
more inexpensive to hold the Bitcoin ETF
for a year than to make one simple trade
on coinbase so obviously there there's
pressure there but also I think there's
a very very big contingency of people
who are educating others about Bitcoin
who say buying the ETF is not buying
Bitcoin right you're buying exposure to
bitcoin but you're not actually buying
the Bitcoin you're not self- custody
that Bitcoin and so what we're going to
see is how many people care about self-
custody versus care about just the
exposure to the price
it can't be good in your term coinbase's
fees coinbase highly blows me no blows
me away whenever I've done anything on
coinbase it's like wait a minute it was
trading here why am I getting and I look
at it I me they're what are they 5% or
something here's here's not the really
interesting idea uh from an investment
perspective is uh the public market
drastically under U or misunderstands a
lot of these crypto businesses in the
sense of coinbase has uh their exchange
fees they have their custody fees they
also have a lot of what I'll call
Crypton native Revenue right so they
have this new blockchain called base and
they're generating a lot of Revenue
there miners a lot of their revenue is
actually driven by the price of Bitcoin
so if the price of Bitcoin doubles their
revenue doubles because the uh revenue
is denominated Bitcoin the fee structure
itself the fee structure it will
compress but they're essentially just
shifting it into more of a crypto native
Revenue stream okay you're an investor
in coinbase so you're looking at all of
this are you more likely to sell based
on this or do you think you're likely to
add to your business I think that any
company in the public markets that is
Crypt native revenue is going to do very
well over the next one to two years so
you're not you're not looking to sell
I'm not definitely not selling so you
say one to two years you think 10
years investing's hard and predicting 10
years out is nearly impossible right um
what I what I think is that this is a
generational Trend where there's an
asset class that didn't exist 15 years
ago now obviously it's not going away
and so if you just look at where is
money where is Talent flowing you got to
say okay crypto is going to be a big
beneficiary over this over the next
decade or so the individual winners
there's always going to be competition
right there's always going to be
newcomers that show up and try to uh uh
you know disrupt the incumbents ETC and
then you also got to look at like what
happens if some of the large Legacy
players do some consolidation with some
of these crypto players like if you know
and again I'm not saying this is going
to happen but let's say that black rock
all of a sudden says let's go buy
coinbase and give them their right
there're T together I need to ask you
this so 900 billion that's a market cap
right so 70% of the holders will never
sell so how much do these ETF that we
talked about how much Bitcoin do they
need to put in where are they going to
get I mean do they need how many billion
do they need to to to to put it in the
ETS and and where are they going to get
it from the 70% is they're going to get
it from the 30% or the 70% willing to
sell at 60,000 70,000 where where do
they get it so my prediction is $2
billion in the next 48 hours into the
ETF so it'll smash every ETF record
launch that we've ever seen that's still
small though compared to 900 50 billion
and there's a there's a multiplier
effect right so $1 in doesn't just mean
$1 in the market cap movement but but
definitely it's not 900 billion um the
second thing is that great scales gbtc
before it had the uh it doesn't have a
Redemption function and so if you go
back to 2020 there was billions of
dollars flowing into that vehicle and
they eventually had about 3.5% of all
the circulating Supply that went into
that fund and we went from $8,000 to
$64,000 in a matter of 6 months and so
what I think people don't uh remember is
that if 70% of that suppli is being held
illiquid by these holders they will sell
at some point it's just going to be at a
much higher price why would they sell
and I thought about it you know got a
tiny amount and if it's going to half a
million dollars I'll never sell but I
look at it I'm thinking wow i' be nice
to get you know 46 is not a bad number
there's a lot of people who sold Amazon
over the years right many other great
Investments but I think wish we don't
know it's an Amazon well it's been
better than Amazon yeah but from here
from from here take a lot of of
intestinal fortitude to buy it at 50,000
well again if you just look at okay have
a finite asset I have a wall of demand
that's coming in right billions of
dollars at at a minimum probably tens of
billions of dollars and it's a
generational asset shift where people
are saying I'm not going to go allocate
to these other assets I'm going to go
use this as my too late is it Andrew I
mean you be crazy one Bitcoin for 50
Grand when you could have bought at five
right well yeah you'll feel bad if if
that's what you're trying to trying to
say I'm not saying you feel bad no I'm
just saying you people you
goty you got to really step up at 50 to
get one Bitcoin so the ETFs also another
really interesting thing is the unit uh
bias is going to change now now all of a
sudden rather than go buy a $50,000
Bitcoin I may be able to buy a $10 share
feel like you're buying and so there's a
very interesting uh Dynamic there that
may shift uh especially people who are
trying to buy that ETF all right that
wasn't too much of a victory lab for you
was it you're humble humble and hungry I
don't to say much I think people realize
that uh you know Bitcoin for 15 years
was knocking on the door look Cameron
and Tyler winlos filed you know 10 12
years ago for this ETF and there's a ton
of people we'd spend hours if I try to
name everyone who was you know had a
hand in making this uh get approved but
it's an ETF on Wall Street now well
that's going to be the last word on it
that we're going to have
today hours Lu to you guys we'll be
talking a lot more about it than 12 more
guests